it's really sticky
[Music]
hi i'm danielle hi i'm micah hi i'm
joelle
hi i'm june hello i'm howard growing up
in san francisco as
a chinese and korean family we
definitely ate a lot of dumplings
growing up
now i'm challenging my family members to
each make their own
individual dumplings and then we're
gonna have a taste test to see whose is
the best
why dumplings are unique because they
look like little um
clams like little ocean bi valve
situation i don't know what i really put
in them
i went more for the aesthetic hopefully
they taste
good so this one is danielle's which is
sort of obvious by the ruffle i think
it's very cute
but not chinese or korean these look
like
uncrustables so i can't say this
particularly
however i shouldn't judge just on
aesthetics
give it a good grade for the way it
looks but danielle always does this and
i always make fun of her for it so
whatever it definitely looks like she
threw some kimchi in there because it's
kind of
pink it's interesting because to fold it
this way you have to add
less filling there's like lots of like
loose skin
i would say this is a pretty good
dumpling as well i
taste the pork first and then i could
also taste a little bit of the chives
this tastes like only pork i like this
one
she had some kimchi for the spice which
i like i do wish she were heavier on the
shrimp though and not the pork because
it is just kind of like
a little meatball i feel like it didn't
have like the normal soy sauce sesame
oil
yeah it just doesn't taste asian but it
tastes fine i give it a solid eight
i think maybe a six only because i don't
like the skin flaps
in eight or nine i really liked it five
to six
[Music]
mine has a little bit of everything it's
just like a solid
pork dumpling i also think that mine are
folded really nicely i actually
made it for myself for lunch today and i
thought they were pretty good
tastes good with soy sauce i think
they're cute it looks
good it's got a little bit of a design
to it it's like a four-fold situation
isn't it like the more folds the longer
you live or something
now it looks like she includes some
veggie which is good because micah
normally doesn't like vegetables that
much
tastes good i think it could have been
flavored a little bit better it seasoned
better
tastes like a meatball texture the
seasoning is very light i kind of wish
she included a little bit more
spice maybe some more like soy sauce or
ginger but i can definitely taste a lot
of garlic
it tastes mostly pork so it's pretty
one-dimensional
i wouldn't change anything about it i
think it's pretty good i think it's like
a seven
i like it with a slash maybe nine it's
kind of bland i would give it maybe like
five a seven
my dumpling is a is just a classic
rendition
added a lot of different types of
seasoning obviously salt and pepper but
also ginger garlic and my
secret ingredient is truffle i can
automatically tell whose everybody is
by the way that they fold their
dumplings so this is dad's
and i like these the most because they
have the most filling so i'm excited to
try my dad's because i know it'll be
very heavily stuffed but i also saw him
put like a lot of very strange
seasonings that
i don't know if they belong in dumplings
[Music]
it's really sticky it like stuck to the
roof of my mouth
my dad used a food processor to blend
everything together i like seeing the
chunks of stuff in it to know that it
was all like
sort of made by hand rather than put in
a food processor
so i i don't really love how it tastes
the texture is a little too much i
actually think it's pretty good
i don't know why i'm so surprised
there's just like a lot in there
i just think there's a little too much
going on i can't really tell what the
distinct flavor is i don't know how to
feel about this one
then i'll give it like a seven five out
of ten
i would say it's an eight out of ten i
would give it a five out of 10 but since
i know howard made it and he never makes
dumplings i would say
for effort a 9 out of 10.
in my dumplings i like to include a lot
of vegetable and honestly
the less meat the better i like seafood
in mine so i added shrimp
but no pork i also like a lot of
different seasonings so i use
five spice i use exo sauce and of course
soy sauce and sesame oil and hopefully
it tastes all right nothing
extraordinary about it but
it looks it looks fine nice folds the
traditional way to wrap things it's
supposed to look like
gold nuggets i think they call it ingots
that the
chinese people use to trade
our kimchi this one's a lot chunkier it
doesn't have the traditional flavor
profile that i'm looking for
i can't put my finger on it it's a
little spicy more spicy than i like
because it has kimchi in it which sadly
i don't like that much
there are lots of vegetables uh lots of
kimchi which i like
i think it's pretty flavorful it feels
very healthy i would want
more meat and more garlic out of 10 i
would give it a good
seven and a half six just keep noticing
how spicy it is
i would rate it in eight out of ten step
in
point five
[Music]
i think i made them the traditional
chinese way the way my mother made them
and she's from sandong province which is
known for all their dumplings and
noodles i added also a little bit of
dofu which
is more an element that my korean
mother-in-law introduced to me
and i made homemade wrappers instead of
the store-bought wrappers
i'm the most excited to try my mom's
because she made these skins by hand
such a luxury to be able to make
homemade skin so i'm really excited
obviously that means that they don't
look as perfect but i don't mind
i hate to say it but it looks the worst
it looks kind of wimpy
and there's no real form to the dumpling
oh tastes like gravy
this one has a very different flavor she
didn't use any kimchi at least not that
i can see
i can definitely taste like the five
spice seasoning that she used
i feel like it has the right level of
juiciness i know some of them like
danielle's a little dry it feels like a
harmony of textures
it's not really that flavorful which is
why i think it tastes like ravioli
i don't like the flavor profile of moms
either it has to be a
nice balance of both meat and some of
the vegetables
i like a little bit of heat i think the
skins really do a lot for it
i probably give this like a nine i give
this a kind of a low score
six i think it's probably a nine out of
ten i think a 6 for dumpling but
a 9 for ravioli
[Music]
yay i won the traditional chinese
flavors taste
the best with the handmade homemade
skins
thank you
you